So the idea was that in looking at thin sections of yeast cells,
one can see some organelles that look like they could be associated with
secretion, not as dramatic as in a section of mammalian cells,
but Novick and I guessed that the vesicles that one sees congregating under the bud portion of a dividing
cell would be the vehicle not only for secretion,
but for assembly of the plasma membrane.
And so we predicted that anything that blocked the biogenesis of these vesicles would be
lethal, and that therefore,
one would have to go after conditional, temperature sensitive, lethal mutations.
So that was the first and crucial assumption that it was going to be an essential
gene.
And the second was that the mutant would,
at a restrictive temperature,
cause secretory proteins, which are otherwise very efficiently secreted from cells, to
be accumulated inside of the cell. And that actually really trivialized it,
you just assay intact cells,
which measures the enzyme that has been trapped in the cell wall,
the cell walls porous.
And then you dissolve the cell wall with an enzyme and you have spheroplasts
that are left and then you just rupture the spheroplasts with a detergent and you assay what's inside the spheroplast.
And that's a measure of accumulation. In a wild type cell, that baseline is virtually
zero. In a sec mutant,
it rises dramatically above the background.
So the first mutant,
just based on a biochemical enzyme assay,
was really obviously blocked in multiple secretory enzyme transport.
But the dramatic result came just around the time George Palade visited Berkeley for a
special lecture,
and I recall Novick telling me that at the luncheon Palade had encouraged him with these
preliminary results to cut a thin section,
to look and see what these cells looked like.
And so we had an expert technical assistant in the department.
And that,
of course,
was one of the great eureka moments of my career when Novick excitedly
called me down to the EM room and showed me these sec1 cell sections
that were just like they had measles,
they were just full of vesicles.
Nothing like that had ever-- at least never been published--
I don't think it had ever been seen before.
And from that moment,
literally from that moment on,
I knew that we would have at least several decades worth of productive work.